I just wanna start off by saying I saw
as a glasses wearer who is constantly
pushing this guy Calvados I just wanna
say how much I appreciate how much your
character in the middle of this massive
gunfight there's a moment where he
pushes his glasses back up on his nose
well that actually happened really I
don't know how many takes it was but
once we got to that sequence the first
time I was sweating so my glass was
slipping so I just as the character it
was just a moment of I'll do that and
then Chad like do it again so uh it was
organic the last time okay let me see if
I can recreate the one so um that's a
good director yeah yeah no I remember
things that happened I remember telling
you sir about David knows we're walking
back to the set and when we were doing
Debra Jenni Tim tells the story David
bang his head on something I'm on the
door David see your cases god damn if I
could become addicted to that I mean
it's like hey dude no but I mean that's
the kind of nowhere you like to do
directors take something that happens to
make it yeah I mean I did something with
us I mean that's it I know it exactly
what you mean but only good directors
with directors who know the actors and
then they can play with that and you
noticed it which is it which is a really
cool thing you know yeah just to sort of
jump off of that I feel like the John
Ricca universe has gotten so big based
on things that were only slightly
mentioned in the first movie did they
mention the high table and now from
learning about the high table and I'm
wondering when in the first movie when
you guys are making the first movie it
was there a sense of how the
possibilities of this world how big
could get or was it do this movie and
see what happens do this movie and see
what happens no no I mean the fact that
it ended I mean it was one of those
movies come to New York for a couple of
weeks have a good time a lot of good
actors involved I mean apart from Lance
myself that well you know Willem Dafoe
yet Johnny Leguizamo and the first one
and you know but I mean but Chad and
Keanu worked together I think they're
the sort of they're the reason why the
story took on it took on is oh and the
film took on his own life and it was an
extension of what board is is like to
see Keanu do honey
terrific displays quite like that
relentless sort of and they identify
with him and he's relentless and he's
caring and somehow it's like you you
feel for him you liked you you love John
wick you mind the guy you know what he's
gone through
you know I mean they gave him the idea
thing of his dogs you know yes puppy and
they killed his wife they killed the
first ball I mean come on you know
anything and I'm interested because to
sort of go before the movies I'm
wondering because your characters both
obviously lived these insane lives
before the Continental but these are all
things that are sort of hinted at and
mentioned I'm wondering if in both of
your heads you have that if you have any
idea of what their lives were like
before the Continental yes I we need to
have back stories about first of all
think we definitely agree on this out
far back we would go at least thirty
years and for me that was even in even
in the first couple films before we it's
because it's interesting we don't really
have we have like a moment in they got
the hit of the second film but we really
don't Iraq except on the foam in the
first two films but um for me my
relationship to him is central to who
the character is amazing amazing uh well
thank you so much for talk to me and
this movie is insane and all the best
ways possible and I hope we keep make
them forever and ever